we recently spoke about the unemployment
rate being three point nine percent and
Donald Trump completely unsere eclis and
unabashedly touting that number as a
major victory for himself after having
called the unemployment employment
numbers fake and false during the Obama
administration you'll remember that
during the Obama administration the
focus was not on the unemployment rate
which Trump claimed to be fake but
rather on the labor force participation
rate and during Obama's presidency the
right and Trump liked to point out that
even if the supposed unemployment rate
was 5% or whatever it was at the time
the real unemployment rate was much
higher Trump said at one point 42
percent was the real unemployment rate
and this relates to labor force
participation and as I've pointed out
before the labor force participation
rate doesn't include college students
who are in school full time
it doesn't include people choosing not
to work because they're so well-off that
they don't have to it doesn't include
retirees the labor force participation
rate is not a good indicator of how the
economy is doing and in fact the better
the economy is doing you can see the
labor force participation rate go down
because people don't need to work it's
also just generally a silly metric
because it's often measured in raw
numbers of workers versus non workers
and if the size of your population grows
over time then the raw numbers are of
even less value to you but let's for a
second apply Trump's own standards to
today's economy a record ninety-five
point seven million people are currently
not in the labor force this is more than
ever before in American history so by
the logic of the right on this issue
shouldn't we be really worried about
this right because the 3.9 percent
unemployment number is clearly a fake
number well no any rational person would
realize that these are two different
measures right we have a at this point
in time record baby boomer retirements
happening meaning lots of people are
leaving the labor force the labor force
participation rate was always a red
herring during Obama's presidency and in
a sense it is the same thing during the
trump presidency
and quite frankly the labor force
participation rate isn't actually as
interesting as the total hypocrisy with
which the same people that slammed
unemployment numbers as fake under Obama
are now completely uncritically citing
them as a defense of the Trump economy
and the same people who touted the labor
force participation rate conspiracy
theories of 42 percent is the real
unemployment during Obama's presidency
they haven't even mentioned that once
under Donald Trump even though that
metric which they talked about is worse
than ever people are going to rush into
the YouTube comments saying but but but
but David the population has grown and
the labor force participation rate
doesn't count retirees and stay-at-home
parents and of course I would say that's
right that's the way it works now and
that's the way it worked under Obama but
you didn't seem to care about that fact
then did you and it is really important
to know what these metrics do measure
and what these metrics don't measure and
what the limits are of what any one
metric can tell us and actually tomorrow
in part two of our interview with Chris
Martenson we're gonna dig into that
specifically and he and I may not always
agree about the relative importance of
any one metric but it's important to
know what is it even measuring and how
is it calculated and has the way that
it's calculated changed over time so
record number of people out of the
workforce our headline for the story
sort of satirical in the sense that no
one all of a sudden on the right cares
about the labor force participation rate
that to tell you a lot about how much
attention it deserves when it was Barack
Obama that was president this episode of
the show is made possible in part by
zipper that's ZPE
our zipper is designing a global
decentralized peer-to-peer alliance
through which companies can provide
secure global and diversified investment
portfolios to minimize risk
zippers initial coin offering for their
new cryptocurrency starts April 16th
zippers goal is to use smart contract
technology to provide a revolutionary
method of funding trans
actions between borrowers and lenders
worldwide and one of the best potential
benefits would be zippers ability to
allow people with no credit to borrow
currency through alternative forms of
verifying creditworthiness on the zipper
blockchain if you're watching this on
YouTube look in the description for a
link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty program this is not financial
advice and of course everyone should do
their own research before spending money
anywhere